dans mon enfance vous dites et ça c'est
c'est grave vous dites il y a une
blessure une blessure de chair un
guérissable quand est-ce que vous en
parlerai
je n'en dirai jamais plus
vos parents ce sont séparés aux étés
très très jeunes ouais donc vous avez
même pas de souvenirs des deux ensemble
non mais j'ai un souvenir de des deux
séparément et j'ai un souvenir des deux
séparément très fort donc effectivement
je j'ai même du mal à les imaginer
ensemble quand je connais leur caractère
vous savez comment ils sont rencontrés
oui
elle est votre mère
fasse part donc votre mère était
mannequin ma mère était
émanciper 15 ans enfin elle a pas connu
mon père à 15 ans je vous rassure tout
de suite mais voilà le vivait sa vie
elle a rencontré qui est libre et et ils
ont eu envie d'en faire un de faire un
enfant tout de suite de dire j'ai été
très désirée
votre mère alors c'est elle qui s'occupe
de vous vous grandissez vraiment avec
elle et c'était une femme quand même
c'est une femme particulière c'est une
femme particulière c'est une femme qui
est très engagée c'est une c'est une en
politique et dans le milieu associatif
et ça ça compte quand même beaucoup
oui c'est à compter dans les deux sens
c'est-à-dire que effectivement moi j'ai
passé toute mon enfance à faire mes
devoirs dans une dans un endroit qui
s'appelait réflexe solidarité où elle
est effectivement les gens qui
n'avaient pas à manger donc elle
s'associe avec les restaurants du cœur
le Secours populaire donc elle avait
beaucoup comme ça le travail dans
l'université des autres et nous tourner
autour et on se disait mais quand est-ce
qu'elle va s'occuper de nous voilà donc
vous aviez mis en même temps un petit
peu
on se disait elle est quand même plus
apte à s'occuper de tous les autres
mômes de la terre plutôt que nous mais
en fait elle nous faisait vivre elle
dans son univers donc réellement oui
militant associatif et dans un premier
temps politique bien sûr dans un premier
temps j'ai eu envie terriblement de fuir
tout ça et de voilà de faire en sorte
que les rideaux puissent être accordés
au tapis que le tapis soit voilà que de
faire de devenir ce qu'on pourrait
appeler une bourgeoise mais je n'ai
jamais dit normal avec des avec des
anormalité c'était mon fantasme je
rêvais de normalité et vous voyez où
j'en suis vous pensez que vous avez
grandi trop vite
oui j'ai grandi trop vite parce que
j'étais l'aîné de 5 enfants et
que j'étais vraiment on m'avait confié
la responsabilité de mes frères puisque
ma sœur est plus petite donc je ne crois
que on a tous grandi très vite dans
cette famille c'est à dire que et en
même temps je ne peux que la remercier
de cet enfant aujourd'hui donc c'est
très contradictoire c'est que oui il y a
une partie de mon enfance qui m'a
qui a été zappé qui m'a échappé
mais en même temps c'est ce qui
structure ma vie d'aujourd'hui
alors une famille très importante chez
manuelle la famille le clan je dirais
même la traiter
et ça c'est grave vous dites il y a une
blessure une blessure de chair un
guérissable quand est-ce que vous en
parlerez
je n'en dirai jamais plus
mais c'est quelque chose de lourd de
pesant
non avec les années je trouve que ce qui
est assez beau c'est que
je crois qu'on part avec beaucoup de
bagages qui ne nous appartiennent pas
et ça c'est une phase de la vie qui moi
m'a paru beaucoup plus difficile à gérer
beaucoup plus difficile à vivre et puis
petit à petit avec la maturité on se
débarrasse de ces bagages qui ne vous
appartiennent pas pour en faire pour en
faire d'autres forces d'autres valises
qui sont les vôtres c'est à dire qu'on
construit je ne crois pas aux Fatalis je
ne suis pas fataliste je crois pas au
destin quand même parce que j'ai une un
fond d'éducation grecque très fort et
que j'ai du mal à m'en débarrasser mais
je crois qu'on peut vraiment changer le
cours des choses il est blessures on
peut les penser oui on peut en faire
quelque chose
il faut qu'on en fasse quelque chose
c'est important alors c'est pas
forcément d'être comédienne mais il faut
que le négatif devienne positif enfin
moi mais je dis ça pour l'enfance je dis
ça pour d'autres choses aussi
c'est-à-dire que j'ai cet art étrange
presque monstrueux de transformer le
négatif en positif et de n'avoir aucune
rancœur
aucune aucun esprit de revanche je ne
connais pas ces mots là voilà je je
trace ma route dans le fond c'est
peut-être d'un grand égoïsme c'est à
dire que je quand les gens sont quand il
y a quelque chose de mauvais négatif je
ferme la porte je trace
[Musique]